مجهول يشعل حرب المزايده على شراء مانشستر
يونايتد السوشيال ميديا تضج بتغييرات
قوانين كره القدم الجديده
ينفق ثروه ضخمه على سياره لم يقودها هذه
الاخبار وغيرها تتابعونها على العربيه
رياضه اسعدوا بمتابعتكم
[موسيقى]
ضجت مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي طوال الساعات
القليله الماضيه بخبر مصادقه المجلس
الدولي لكره القدم في اجتماعه الاخير على
عدد من التغييرات المتعلقه بقوانين اللعبه
وبين مؤيدا لمن صدر من توضيحات واخر معارض
لها الامر المؤكد هنا ان الاتفاق تم على
بث جميع قرارات الفار المتعلقه بعمليه
مراجعه لقطات الفيديو عند الاستعانه بحكم
الفيديو المساعد وعرضها للجمهور في الملعب
ولشاهدي النقل المباشر على شاشات التلفاز
اشعل شخص مجهول الهويه حرب المزايده على
شراء نادي مانشستر يونايتد بالانجليزيه
خلال الفتره المقبله اداره الشياطين للحمر
تلقت عرضين من الشيخ جاسم بن حمد الثاني
نجل رئيس الوزراء القطري السابق والاخر من
السر جبرات كلف غير انهما لم يقدمه اكثر
من اربعه مليارات ونصف المليار جنيه
استرليني وبحسب صحيفه تصن فان اجتماعا
سيعقد خلال الاسبوعين المقبلين من اجل
مناقشه العروض المقدمه للشراء نشرتا الى
وجود عرض ثالث جديد من طرف مجهول الهويه
لم يتم الاعلان عن اسمه بعد ولكن مقره
بحسب المنشور في الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
كعادته نجوم المستطيل الاخضر قرر الفرنسي
كيليان مبابي شراء سياره جديده من ماركه
فرار الايطاليه المعروفه حتى الان لا جديد
في الخبر بغض النظر عن السياره التي
اختارها على وجه التحديد او حتى سعرها
الذي يصل تقريبا لنصف مليون يورو الغريب
هنا ان مهاجم باريس سان جيرمان الفرنسي لن
يتمكن للاسف من الاستمتاع بسيارته الجديده
بالشكل المطلوب والسبب ببساطه هو عدم
امتلاكه لرخصه قياده فهي ليست من اولوياته
بحسب اللاعب لان لديه سائقين تحت التصرفه
في اي وقت ولله في خلقه شؤون
الختام من باريس وتحديدا مع الاسطوره
البرازيلي رونالدو وخطيبته سيرينولوكس
اللذين استطاع خطف الانظار في عرض ازياء
فيكتوريا بيكام الصحافه والخضور قامت
بتركيز على الثنائي واجتماعه مع ثنائيا
اخر الانجليزي ديفيد بكم وزميله زميله
السابق في ريال مدريد الاسباني بين عامي
2003 و207 وزوجاته صاحبه العرض فيكتوريا